رخصه مزاوله مهنه التعليم في مصر مشروع
قانون سيقدم لمجلس النواب المصري يهدف
لتطوير ملف التعليم ومواجهه الدروس
الخصوصيه التي تشكل ازمه النميقه تواجه
كثيرا من البيوت المصريه الوزاره هي التي
ستمنح رخصه مزاوله مهنه معلم بعد عدد من
الاختبارات يخضع لها المتقدم للحصول عليها
في مصر وعلى مدار سنوات
تكافح الحكومه مراكز الدروس الخصوصيه
الممنوعه اصلا بموجب القانون لكنها اصبحت
ظاهره ومنظومه تعليميه موازيه تشكل هناك
مقرا للعشرات من التلاميذ في فصول مزدحمه
وتمتد لتشمل طلاب المرحله الابتدائيه حتى
ويطلقوا المدرسون الذين يديرون هذه
المراكز اسماءا على انفسهم مثل مايسترو
الالماني فارس الكيمياء رئيس جمهوريه
اللغه العربيه
افلاطون الفلسفه وملك الحساب وغيرها من
الاسماء وزير الا التربيه والتعليم المصري
الذي اعتبر تصريحاته حول تقنين سناتر
التعليم فهمت بشكل خاطئ تحدث عن انفاق
اكثر من 47 مليار جنيه على الدروس
الخصوصيه بينما تقرير الجهاز المركزي
للتعبئه والاحصاء يكشف عن انفاق الاسره
المصريه اكثر من 100 و36 مليار جنيه سنويا
لما تقتصر اقتراحات الوزير على مراكز
الدروس وانما امتدت لتشمل مجموعات التقويه
التي تنظمها المدارس الحكوميه كاداه
لمكافحه الدروس الخصوصيه واعتبر ان هذه
المجموعات غير فعاله معلنا اسنادها لشركه
خاصه لادارتها